monkeys and coconuts monkeys and
coconuts yeah so this is this is an old
problem that was set by a guy called ben
amos williams in uh the saturday evening
post in the in the 1920s they were
inundated with uh frustrated readers
desperate to know the answer couldn't
work it out in fact the the editor at
the time who's a guy called george
horace lorimer i think more people
should be called horus nowadays george
horace laura murray wrote to williams
who'd set the problem and was like you
know for the love of mike what's the
answer i don't know why i use mike but
okay
it was also popularized by by martin
gardner later on it's one of his
problems uh but yeah so i thought i
thought we could we could talk about the
monkey and the coconut problem
so basically the story goes that you've
got five sailors and they're shipwrecked
on a desert island and there's a monkey
as well
and they go around and they collect a
bunch of coconuts and then they go to
sleep in the middle of the night one of
them wakes up he's looking at the
coconuts he thinks there's going to be
trouble in the morning so he goes over
and he starts separating them out you
know amongst the five sailors and then
there's one left over she chucks to the
monkey who's watching the whole thing
right he stashes his pile hides it and
then puts the rest together puts it back
in the middle so then the next sailor
wakes up and he hasn't realized what's
happened he does the same thing okay so
he stashes a pile gives one to the
monkey and then puts the rest together
and then the next sailor wakes up and he
hasn't realized he does the same thing
each time the monkey gets one but the
pile of course is getting smaller and
smaller and smaller and smaller anyway
come morning time all the sailors have
done this the piles got pretty rubbish
by this stage and they all realize that
there's been a bit of naughtiness going
on in the middle of the night but none
of them say anything because they're all
feeling guilty so then they just go
ahead and they they separate the pile
and it goes evenly five ways
okay the monkey doesn't get one this
time
so then the question is how many
coconuts were there to begin with
probably people should pause at this
point and go away and try to calculate
it
so the answer is
drum roll please all right
three thousand one hundred and twenty
one
okay
now that's
seems a bit unsatisfactory so why is
that the answer so to try and understand
where this number comes from we're gonna
begin by trying to solve a slightly
easier problem
okay and the problem we're gonna solve
is in the scenario we described the
monkey didn't get one on the in the
final separation right now we're gonna
say he does here's what's going on right
so you start off with some coconuts
let's call it c naught the original
amount of coconuts and what happens to
your c naught well you give one to the
monkey
okay and the rest gets separated five
ways
so each
pile contains s1 what does that stand
for that's just the number in in in the
piles when you do the fair separations
okay and one for the one key then that
first sailor takes his pile hides it how
many coconuts are you left with well
you're left with four s one right
because there's four piles left then
that four gets separated one gets given
to the monkey
and
the rest go five ways
in this case it continues all the way
down right okay because at each stage
even the very last stage the monkey gets
one so on the final
separation we have the following so the
fifth pile has four times s5
and this one again will go
five ways with the one left for the
monkey so this is the sort of you know
the problem what you're really after is
this numbers c naught just the original
number of uh of coconuts so we want to
relate this guy to this guy
and we end up with the following
equation which as i'm going to write it
is not particularly illuminating but let
me just write it anyway
where'd that come from
you've got a bunch of equations here and
you can just eliminate say from these
two equations you could eliminate s1
and then give you c naught in terms of
s2 and then you keep iterating that
process and you end up with this
equation okay i'm taking your word for
it yeah it's it's it's tedious this is
an example of a linear theophantine
equation it's got it's a linear equation
and it's got it's different sign because
we're looking for integer solutions
these guys have got to be integers now
there are standard uh methods for
solving these kinds of things laid down
by euclid there is an ingenious solution
to this problem which which i
particularly like it's sometimes
attributed to dirac the great dirac he
himself sort of tried to deny that that
he'd come up with it said he got it from
a guy called whitehead it's not clear
where the original solution came from
but anyway dirac seems to be the first
point of contact for this the idea is to
consider negative coconuts
let me just rewrite this equation a
little bit so this first number here
this 1024
is actually four to the power five
okay this is just useful to to know to
see some structure in the equation this
number here is five to the power 6 and
this number here
is 5 to the 6 minus 4 to the 6.
so you can check that they happen to be
the same numbers and of course it's
related to the fours and the fives that
are in the original problem so the first
thing you notice about this equation is
it has a symmetry what you can notice is
if i take a c naught if i have some
solution c naught
of this equation if i happen to know a
solution and i shift it by 5 to the 6
and at the same time i shift the s6
by four to the five
it will still be a solution yeah you can
see that just add five to the six to c
naught
you get then you get a correction on
this side of four to the five times 5 to
the 6th and if you add 4 to the 5 to s6
you get a correction of 5 to 6 times 4
to the 5. the equation's still solved
okay so all i need to know is find one
solution then i'll have an infinite
number i just keep adding these values
and i still have solutions so actually
there's an infinite number of solutions
this problem if there is one there's an
infinite number so all i have to do is
come up with one
and it doesn't matter if it's made out
of negative or positive coconuts all i
do is i just get the the negative value
and i keep adding this until i get the
first positive value that's the idea and
then you see it's really easy to find an
answer with negative coconuts he just
rearranged the equation slightly
bring this four over to this side okay
and then
do a little manipulation
you should be able to convince yourself
that this equation now holds
okay so what i've done here is i've
taken this 5 to the 6
and factored it out
and i've taken this four to six over
and i've again factored it out a factor
of four to the five now it's easy to
spot a solution to this equation though
he's five ready no it's easy come on no
just make both sides naught
if you make both sides naught then that
corresponds to c naught is equal to
minus four
and s six is equal to minus one that's
of course minus four coconuts which is
ridiculous but it can see it makes sense
actually think about what happens if you
start with minus four coconuts minus
four coconuts give one to the monkey how
many have you got minus five
minus five divides equally between five
so each pile then has minus one coconuts
in it four of them get put into the next
batch so you have minus four in the next
batch and the process is just
it's sort of it's the same at each stage
so this is why minus four works but of
course
who has minus four coconuts so the
answer is just to add five to the six
because remember it i can just add 5 to
the 6 to any answer and it gives me
another answer the smallest positive
instant answer is of course
5 to the 6 minus 4
which is in this case 15 6 2 1
okay so that's the solution to the
simpler problem
okay it's a bigger number it's a bigger
number well the monkey's getting more
coconuts this time right but actually
it's kind of weird the monkey gets one
more coconut and you and yeah he ends up
you need 12 000 luck more coconuts to
begin with kind of crazy so now let's
just think about the original problem
that we wanted to solve and the idea is
is fairly similar except you need some
blue coconuts
you need some blue coconuts yeah so what
we're going to do is we're going to take
our original pile but what we're going
to do is we're going to add four blue
coconuts to the pile and you forget
about the monkey so now what happened
was you've got your warm coconut that
you gave to the monkey
in the original problem
but now you're going to put that with
the four blue coconuts that makes five
that splits evenly between five so this
is where the trick comes in so what you
do is add four blue coconuts forget the
monkey the first sailor wakes up in the
night splits them five ways puts one
blue coconut on four piles four
different piles
keeps the blue free pile for himself and
stashes it now the problem is very
simple
first stage
it just splits five ways
okay
and then you go to the next stage
and these you lose one pile so it goes
down to four and then
you split that one five ways now what
you can clearly see is as you're doing
this
is that the pile of total number of
coconuts blue and ordinary ones is
depleting by four fifths at each stage
that seems clear right
these are tildes so by the time you've
got to the last step
the pile of coconuts if it's depleted by
four-fifths to the power five because
you've done five steps but these aren't
actually the amount of coconuts that we
want okay this is this isn't quite the
number we want the until the numbers so
the first step this this number here
this c naught tilde is of course
c naught plus four
this
c five tilde
which is c five plus four okay which is
the number of uh coconuts that you ended
up with now this number here
is a multiple of five
right because remember
in the original story laid down by
williams the last pile really does split
amongst five people and there's not one
left over for the for the monkey so this
should be a multiple of five so let me
just call that five n so this is now the
problem that you're looking at
so let me rearrange it slightly let me
write it as
five to the five
five n plus four just multiplying three
by this five to the five four to the
five
c naught plus four
and now again i've got a d a linear d
fan sign equation again i can i could
use the the standard methods blah blah
blah but i'm not gonna do that we're
gonna be clever about it let me just
call this number
uh well i mean i know what i called i
called it c5 tilde okay
and this is c naught tilde so now i if
i'm looking for integers i know that c
five tilde and c naught tilde are
integers they certainly are if i find a
solution c naught tilde then i can
certainly add to it
five to the five
and similarly to c five tilde i can
always add to that
four to the five by the same logic as in
the previous case i go for the easiest
case that c naught tilde and c5 tilde
are both zero to solve this equation now
is that a good solution
okay so let's see if c5 tilde is zero
that implies that n is minus four fifths
which is not so good because that's not
an integer
okay so that hasn't worked so then we go
to our next solution which is of course
c5 tilde we just have to have four to
the five to it
four to the five okay now this is good
because
that implies
that n
is equal to
four to the five minus four divided by
five if you rearrange this equation so
that is i think 204 so that is an
integer solution so this guy works so we
just have to work out what the
corresponding c naught is the
corresponding c naught tilde is zero
plus five to the five so it's five to
the five so c naught tilde is five to
the five
which means that c naught
is five to the five minus four
which is three one two one
if you ever want to know about
how many coconuts you need to feed the
shipwreck guys in the monkeys there you
go job done
look you did it on the back of an
envelope literally out front of an
envelope in it
oh yeah that's it
so there you go it's quite quite you
know just a bit of fun with one of these
recreational math problems but um do you
think that was really simple
um
i mean it was never going to be simple
because at the end of the day uh you
know have people
cry left right and said to the saturday
evening post uh begging them for the
solution but uh
there it is